Speaker 1: All right. So listen, some of you
know who John Campbell is. Some of you don't.
John Campbell is a Ph.D. in nursing who has a
YouTube channel that blew up during the COVID
pandemic. And he would provide a mix of sensible
information and analysis, but he would also dabble
in anti-vax and some sort of stranger stuff that
he would flirt with. And people would write to
me and they would say, David. Dr. John Campbell
is a doctor who knows about all this stuff. Why?
Why aren't you in lockstep with him? And, you
know, when when we talk about Dr. Jill Biden.
She has a Ph.D. in education. There is no
possibility that anybody thinks Joe Biden
is a medical doctor but not a medical doctor, a
Ph.D. in education. The difficulty with Dr. John
Campbell is that he is talking about medicine.
He's talking about medications and vaccines
and treatments and pandemics. He has a Ph.D.
in nursing specializing in online teaching.
Okay. Now, this doesn't mean that everything John
Campbell says is wrong, but so many people see
someone called Dr. John Campbell talking about
medicine and they assume you're talking about a
medical doctor. It's not that a Ph.D. in nursing
is worthless. It's just that he's not a medical
doctor. And during the pandemic, people would
email me, email me, email me saying, listen to
this doctor and what he's saying, okay? He now is
feigning outrage that a new Amrani flu vaccine.
Is doing phase one trials with only 50 people.
Except that's what phase one trials are. And he
has even said that without feigning outrage
in the past. So this is another example,
creating fear, generating uncertainty, firing
people up. Let's listen. Here he is talking
about the clinical trials of the MRSA flu vaccine.
Speaker 4: The number involved up to 50 healthy
volunteers, 18 through to 49 years of age. So
this is direct from their website. This is not
me. This is not me having a joke here.
Speaker 1: They're not a joke,
guys. They really have only 50 people.
Speaker 4: Claiming the National Institutes
of Health in the United States are claiming. That
by testing 50 volunteers healthy 18 through to 49.
They can assess the safety of this vaccine.
Speaker 1: Okay. How? How dare they? Now,
if you do any research, you find that
phase one clinical trials start with 20
to 80 people and you only need to look at his
own prior statements about phase one clinical
trials to realize that the feigned outrage is
fake. Here is Dr. John Campbell in February
of 2020. This is great video compiled by the Bad
Stats Twitter channel. They do a really good job
where he says this is typical.
Speaker 4: Vaccine and the China vaccine are now
being tested for safety in animals. Now, the next
stage after this, in early spring will be phase
one human trials now in phase one clinical trials.
The drug or the vaccine in this case is given to
a relatively small amount of healthy volunteers.
Speaker 1: Totally normal in phase one clinical
trials. It's given to a small number of
healthy volunteers. August of 2022, same thing.
Speaker 4: Now, that's the molecule. They're
apparently right. Phase one trial has been done on
healthy volunteers already. So this is in way on
its way. Next few months, report from 42 patients.
And if that's a good quality. No.
Speaker 1: No, no problem there.
Okay. So listen, this is not about. To be honest,
I haven't seen any of John Campbell's content for
a long time now. It's not about going after him
as a bad person or whatever. What I can tell you
is the following. There is no reason to now start
stoking skepticism about the Moderna flu vaccine
because the Phase one trial has 50 people.
That's normal. John Campbell has on numerous
occasions told us phase one trials have
a small number of people. Here's one with
42 people not totally non-reactive. And now
he feigns outrage. It's not a joke, folks.
They're really assessing this based on 50 people.
That's how a phase one trial works. So, you know,
again, just understand what your sources are.
Google simple things. It would take one second
to say how many people are normally in a phase one
clinical trial. There is nothing to be outraged
about. I very much look forward to the data
about this marina flu vaccine. Maybe we will
get ourselves a flu vaccine that is more effective
than the ones that have sometimes floated around
over the last few years, which sometimes are only
20 to 40% effective. Sometimes it's more, but
sometimes it's only 20 to 40%. I would love a more
effective flu vaccine. That should be the focus.